so last night we talked to a lawyer who
represented January 6 defendant Jacob
chansley the so-called Q Anon Shaman the
lawyer told us that the government the
prosecutors in this case in violation of
the Constitution hid exculpatory
evidence from him and the defense in
order to send Jacob chansley to prison
for four years where he is tonight now
we showed you that evidence this week
it's surveillance footage that shows
Federal officers leading Jacob chansley
around the capitol like tour guides at
one point they even opened the door of
the hollowed Senate chamber for him and
Usher him in
so the tape proves conclusively that
Jacob chance used every action inside
the building was videotaped committed no
felony and the government hid that fact
and because they did the media were
allowed to paint Jacob chancelly as a
dangerous terrorist who deserved to be
killed
you know I think the most amazing thing
about the whole thing is watching the
video
and on the senate floor there's a cop
who's armed and a guy bursts in the Q
Anon Shaman dressed like a viking and he
basically talks to him you're I'm
watching shoot him shoot him like if it
you burst into the United States that if
he was dressed like Bin Laden would have
shot him
imagine if they said that about
someone you loved well now we know that
the bite Administration created that
perception that this man should be
killed and then broke the law
specifically to destroy the life of
American citizen and Naval veteran Jacob
Chansey again remains in prison tonight
the question is what happens next Martha
chansley is jacobsey's Mother William
Shipley is his attorney and they join us
tonight Martha Chansey thank you so much
first to you what's it like what has it
been like for the last 26 months to see
people like Steve Schmidt of a Lincoln
project on television calling for the
killing of your son
what has it been like that's it's an
awful thing to say that's it it's
horrible
I
I can't even I honestly I can't even
imagine even saying that for somebody
who just walked through open doors
yes right how
does it feel to know that the U.S
government the Biden Administration hid
this evidence and on the basis of that
lie and crime sent your son to prison
for years
It's upsetting It's upsetting it should
have come out all
two years ago that should have come out
two years ago he's he's an innocent man
everything that he said that he did is
true that he walked through open doors
he was escorted through the the halls in
the Senate and part of the reason why he
was as escorted was because he
volunteered to help them he said that he
saw people in the Senate and that he
wanted to help them uh
in any way he could
yeah and that's why part of the reason
why he was led around
it's very obvious Mr Shippy thank you
for joining us tonight so this show
confirmed thank you
well of course we've confirmed today
that the Capitol Police turned over all
the video including the video you just
saw of Jacob Chancellor your client to
the FBI right after January 6. so the
FBI had this videotape and they withheld
it from his initial lawyer in his
defense how is he still in prison
tonight
that's a great question
sorry am I supposed to say or is no I
was just asking the attorney here as a
legal matter how is this okay how is
your son still behind bars
well Jake did not have a lot of
post-conviction options uh the plea
agreement that Albert Watkins talked him
into signing waived all his appeal
rights so he had no opportunity to go to
the Circuit Court of Appeals to raise
any issues connected to his conviction
he had limited rights to challenge the
performance of Albert Watkins as his
lawyer when I came into the case that's
the first subject I began discussing
with him was my criticisms of what
Watkins talked him into doing it was
terrible plea agreement it was an
unconscionable plea agreement I've done
this for 35 years I I recognized
immediately what Watkins had done wrong
Watkins had him plead guilty before the
government was even willing to say it
had produced all the video the
government in August of 2021 was still
telling judges we haven't been able to
get all of the evidence to defense
lawyers so please don't set trial dates
Albert Watkins didn't care he convinced
his client to take the offer the
government made and plead guilty so he's
in a little bit of a mousetrap so but
now that we know that this was a a
travesty I mean the people responsible
for it should be punished Liz Cheney
should lose her job today as a professor
at the University of Virginia she knew
this she destroyed a man's life but how
do you get Jacob chancelly out of jail
now well we're looking at that I'm not
sure there's an easy solution there's
not an easy road to that to get the
matter back in before judge Lamberth in
the The District Court here and to have
him reconsider a sentence uh in many
ways it's procedurally barred we're
going to have to come up with a creative
way to get it back before judge Lambert
frankly I think judge Lambeth may be a
little bit um unhappy that uh you know
the government presented some videos
after sentencing to paint Jacob in the
worst possible light the way they
described him in court as you know the
face of the Insurrection uh violent and
then you know judge Lambert frankly he
gave him the sentence that Albert
Watkins negotiated the sentence in the
agreement was 41 to 51 months and judge
Lambeth gave him 41 months but I don't
think judge Lambert today probably
thinks he saw everything he needed to
see when he made that decision yeah I
mean this is just an open and shut
travesty as far as I'm concerned and and
Godspeed to both of you getting this
unjustly convicted man out of jail
Martha chansley William Shipley his
attorney thank you both very much
thank you Tucker thank you very much we
really appreciate you thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight